myself to welcome you all here today
Department buildings for this meeting or
for special British Iris parliamentary
assembly and I want to thank your
co-chair Parsons Brandon Smith and Karen
Bradley for the opportunity to speak to
you today
and it is a very good uh to see so many
familiar faces around the chamber this
morning
I'm delighted to be able to host this
session this morning in the chamber for
two reasons actually first of all it is
very fitting that you are here during
the 25th anniversary of the good trade
agreement period and secondly I do
strongly believe that inter
parliamentary relations are indeed
extremely important
you should know that we are counting
your session today as the first author
program of events and initiative to mark
this Milestone here in Parliament
buildings
now we cannot deny that there have been
delays and disappointments over the
years which have replaced much of the
Hope on optimism in 1998 with public
some cynicism and frustration indeed
however we are sometimes in danger of
forgetting how far we have come
how hard won the agreement was and how
challenging achieving agreement is
indeed in a divided Society not only is
it the 25th anniversary of the agreement
it's also the 25th anniversary of the
establishment of this particular
assembly
and that is particularly important for
us to remember because the assembly is
essentially and should be the heartbeat
of our politics
as a standard piece of the agreement we
also have to acknowledge that when the
assembly is not operating it has a dead
hand impact on the other key
institutions and indeed on our body
Politics as a whole
all parliamentary institutions evolve
and while we have the bit about reform
at this time in my view I think it is to
we have to recognize that the
institutions have not been working
totally for 25 years and therefore we
have lost valuable time in which we
would have evolved in the natural course
of events now this anniversary year
is an opportunity for us collectively to
reflect on to focus on building for the
future
if they had
my reflection would be that over the 25
years we have understandably had much
focus on the executive but arguably to
the detlement of the assembly itself
over the past three years old Facebook
and I have frequently discussed issues
in the context of enabling a
parliamentary culture and I think that
the development of the assembly itself
is a key issue for the future discussion
and we're parliamentary releases are
another issue which I view as being
vital to the Future development of the
assembly
The Great Frederick saw transformation
of relationships across and between our
respective legislators and that has been
very very important and an important
means of continuing that process our
speaker have also had the privilege of
welcoming many International diplomats
and guests and parliamentary delegations
and that is only served the underlying
continually to me how much Good Will and
support that there is available to us
particularly if we have political
stability established
while they're exactly when the ministers
have the key role in building our
external relationships the assembly also
has an opportunity to build on these
relationships and opportunities
connections with other parliaments can
be an essential element
can be an essential element of doing
that both formally and and formally
about 10 days ago I had the pleasure of
Hosting discussions between the speakers
and Poseidon officers and the Kim corla
from Westminster the Iraqis Edinburgh
and Cardiff
Peppa has also shown herself to be a
most valuable platform for continuing
the dialogue across these islands
so I would certainly be encouraging that
the assembly take up a more strategic
approach to parliamentary relations in
the time ahead I would just hope that we
get to that point sooner rather than
later
the anniversary this year is an
opportunity for us to all collectively
reflect and focus on building for the
future so thank you all again Karen and
Brandon and I know that you have a busy
program of sessions ahead today so I
look forward to hosting the loans for
you all today and continuing our
conversation so all I would finally say
is good luck I'm worthy at this
particular point in time of your
deliveries and so thank you all very
much
Mr Speaker on behalf of the assembly I
would like to thank you for addressing
us here today for your warm welcome to
Belfast and for generously allowing us
allowing the assembly to meet in these
Splendid surroundings it's an honor to
be here and to support your aims to
instill a parliamentary culture here in
Stormont which bipper can I know be a
key part of so thank you
see there
we now resume our usual order of
business could ask members when they are
invited to contribute from the floor
they would clearly save their name and
legislature if possible members are
encouraged to stand when speaking as
this would support the broadcast of the
assembly which is live via the Northern
Ireland assembly website if members
prefer they may of course remain seated
when speaking
noting the proceedings are public and
being live streamed on the Northern
Ireland assembly website may I remind
members that the proceedings of this
body do not attract parliamentary
privilege members would like to repeat
the speaker's welcome to Belfast and
echo my co-chairs Karen's thanks to him
for his welcome and for allowing us the
use of this fine chamber for our
proceedings today
we are delighted to be holding the 63rd
extraordinary clean recession of the
British Irish parliamentary assembly in
Belfast as we Mark the 25th anniversary
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement we
would be hearing today from some of
those who were directly involved in the
peace negotiations leading to the
signing of the agreement we would have
the opportunity to hear about the
significance of the agreement reflect on
its achievements recognize the areas
that still need implementation and we
look to the Future
you've all been circulated with an
up-to-date list of bipper membership in
your briefing packs I have to inform the
assembly also that accordions would rule
2A the following associate members have
accepted the invitation of the steering
committee to assume the powers and
responsibilities of members for the
whole of this session Jackie died price
MP baroness Hooper Lord Clooney baroness
Ritchie of John Patrick Rose Conway
Walsh TD and Kevin Campbell remember the
Senate Carl Biden MLA and Deputy Chris
Blinn
apologies we've received apologies for
the premium recession from Alistair
Carmichael MP Lord Donahue Laura dubs
Damian green MP Stephen Hammond MP Sarah
Jones MP Conor mcginner MP Nigel Mills
MP Circle car TD Patrick Castro TD Sean
Pro TD Peter fitzpatru TD John Paul feed
and TD Senator Vincent P Martin headed
Falcon member of the Senate patchy and
Emily and Deputy Adam Brewer
foreign
I am delighted to welcome members here
today for our 63rd plenary session of
the British Irish parliamentary assembly
members will have received a copy of the
program of business
it is highly appropriate that our
assembly should meet here to Mark the
25th anniversary of the signing of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement we look
forward to stimulating discussions and
debates
we will shortly hear from the former
t-shirt Mr bertia Hearn and and Sir John
Holmes principal private secretary to
both Tony Blair and Sir John Major
during their premierships
both will address the assembly and then
respond to questions
after short coffee break the morning
session will conclude with a panel
discussion on the women's Coalition and
the Good Friday agreement
the panel comprises of founding members
of the Northern Ireland women's
coalition
there will then be an opportunity for
questions
the afternoon session will begin with an
address from Dr Johnny Byrne Ulster
University on policing under the Belfast
Good Friday agreement and following
which we will hold a debate by members
on policing under the Belfast Good
Friday agreement
our proceedings today will conclude with
a debate on a motion on the Belfast Good
Friday agreement and the assembly will
adjourn not later than 4 45 pm
given we have a full agenda today can I
ask that all members keep their
questions and contributions short during
the course of the day
I will now ask Steve Aitkin MLA to
formally move that the adoption of the
pros the program of business be agreed
to
thank you indeed co-chairs on behalf of
all the mlas in this assembly I would
like to say first of all thank you very
much indeed for coming here and secondly
uh we are the ones who should be in here
all of MLA is doing our own job today
not you being in here but I welcome you
no matter what but thank you all for
very much income indeed and may I
propose formally propose the agenda
thank you
is that agreed
I know I now call on former t-shock
birthday herden to give his address
um I figured you heard you are very
welcome we are absolutely delighted that
you're here with us today we are very
conscious of your ongoing commitment to
peace building and conflict resolution
both at home and around the world
so we're deep in the ready
thank you
thank you very much co-chairs and
thank you very much to
uh for the invitation the speaker to use
this beautiful
assembly as well my previous visits here
were usually from up there uh watching
down on the activities I look forward to
that day again hopefully not too long so
we'll have the opportunity again to be
here just to uh I want to hit just on
two or three uh points and I understand
there might be some questions if there
isn't glad to try and answer those but
first of all I remember back when the
um 1990 when the British Irish
parliamentary assembly or then what it
was the inter-parliamentary body was was
set up it was after a particularly
difficult period
um in the late 80s when perhaps our
relations weren't as good as they could
be and the idea was to try and get
parliamentarians together from
um from London and from Dublin and I
think it it proved to be a very good
buddy I had the opportunity a number of
times over the years of of meeting at
the assembly and its original format and
then in its in in this format so a
manner to be to be heard again and wish
you well for your deliberations and for
your for your meetings I have found it
over the years to be very useful and it
was a very useful and successful way of
us getting to know members from the Lord
in the Commons and that was I think it's
primary aim where we were able to to
build up a good relationships and
understand each other uh better than
what was maybe the 1980s microphone
arguments that went on between us and so
I wish you well in all your work
I suppose the history I'm delighted to
be with John home John Holmes and I
battled together
um well over the years he was with John
major first and then with Tony Blair and
appreciate it always the the long
meetings I'm not sure he and his
colleagues appreciated the length of the
meetings that used to go on and
particularly in the Rose Garden and and
elsewhere when we were in number 10 but
I certainly appreciated it it's worth in
this uh his guidance and his his help
over all over those years we haven't met
for many many years so delighted to meet
him I suppose I just want to to touch
very briefly on on the history
um it is this occasion is to Mark the
25th anniversary
of the good Pride agreement and I
suppose it is extraordinary when we did
negotiate that and all the people that
were involved in it and I want to
particularly
mention all the people from all the
parties but Victory mentioned those that
are no longer with us people like John
Hume and Seamus Mallon and Mark McGinnis
and Davey Irvine momoland and others who
who were such a part of that agreement
and
my partner everybody's partner they're
always missed their role in it and they
the part they played was was enormous
um when when I took up the um
the the involvement I've been involved
in the early 90s when John Wilson had
been chair of the talks the multi-party
talks at that stage 91 92 but then later
on when I was over from where Albert
Reynolds and next spring
um had brought us to the down the street
declaration and then on to the work
where where we were uh it was the view
that if we could get the old party talks
and the multi-party talks going which we
did in September of 97 that at least we
had a an opportunity of trying to get
discussions uh I'd love to bring it
through that winter or Autumn winter and
spring of 97 98 but time won't allow to
do that other than to say that was very
interesting at times uh entertaining but
mainly difficult
um at periods and the one thing I
learned in that period in my life was
how even breaks even for Christmas that
wasn't a good idea because as soon as
you allowed a vacuum you could be
guaranteed that you're in trouble and we
had many problems during that winter
from
a political violence and paramilitary
violence to
um having to put people out of talks and
try and get people back into talks and
and go on moving on and from time to
time when we we went all the way from
September to March and I really felt we
seemed to be going backwards every day
and I know there are people in this room
would remember a lot of those moves back
and forward the way they went but
perseverance and I remember when your
your members here today Paul Murphy will
remember when we got to St Patrick's Day
um we seem to be going nowhere but
George Mitchell decided that he was fed
up with it and then we were going to get
out of here in a hurry and if he was
going home to his uh his wife and baby
as was then for St Patrick's Day or for
Easter
um and Tony Blair decided he was going
to Spain to meet the Prime Minister
Asner
um and I decided that the league final
wasn't called Park so I was going to go
back to see that so anyway I hadn't got
far to go but anyway
um it did put a focus on the talks of
where we would go and you know huge
commitment huge effort my
congratulations to all the people who
played their part in that but if you
looked at the kind of issues we were
trying to deal with and only to mention
them briefly the the core principles to
get it a devolved Administration to get
a north-south bodies to get East-West
institutions
to deal with citizens rights to see how
we could start the process of an
agreement that gets police reform
recognition of Northern Ireland as a
sovereign part of the UK along with a
democratic path tonight Ireland a
commitment to European level human
rights principles protections and
processes to see how we would structure
Northern Ireland to 70 elected by
proportional representation an executive
appointed to provide guaranteed all
parting Community representatives
of Minister serving under a joint and
Deputy joint minister of cross-border
bodies operating north and south and
trade and business had to set up
structures for EU funding food safety
inland waterways Lux management language
promotion International tourism a
British Irish Council that was
representative of the administrations of
these islands a British Irish into
governmental Council of both Sovereign
governments a decommissioning body to
oversee and report and destruction of
paramilitary weapons a new police force
and Police Service in Northern Ireland
to replace the Royal Lobster
considerably and that is mainly the core
principles are not going to go through
any of them or all of them but just to
give you what the agenda was and I
suppose extraordinarily
um we did
manage to to find a way in a relatively
short period of time of agreeing at
least the structures of course they did
not happen on the day the Chris Patton
took up the mantle of the policing issue
and now it's seen this massively
successful all over the world the work
that that commission did
decommissioning it was an issue that we
struggled with
probably the one issue you have had it
all over again I would have done
differently to how we we did it we it
dragged out so long that it was painful
and divisive but most of the issues have
worked away with good stability of
course I think the piece has worked
um the main function of the whole
agreement was that we I suppose I always
looked in two sections Wonder was the
peace process that we would bring peace
and stability away from you know the
huge Carnage that we've seen for 25
years
um and then then we would do with the
political process I always feel that the
the first bit maybe not totally perfect
but fairly close to it
um the second bit up and down and the
fact that these institutions have been
struggling
um for so many uh times and probably 60
percent of the time has not been quite
quite frankly but hopefully that will
change in the in the short term again
though I must say and is talking to the
speaker this morning it's very
impressive what has been achieved when
it institutions have been up their
legitive program their private members
bills
um perhaps that's issue that certainly
from Iraq this air and we don't pass
that many
private member bills at least we didn't
and my 24 years that
were passed and then enacted into law
they've been very impressive what they
have done here in the years that things
were working well so my congratulations
to people on that and hopefully they'll
be able to uh to get to that situation
again
um so we're not going you you understand
the ups and downs I'm not going to do
that I want that question two ways that
in in my time that I think are important
um I I feel passionate about
um the the north south and the East-West
relationships and particularly because
you're all here today and the East
Westing is is the East West institutions
are very important
um it worries me at times when I hear
people saying because the United Kingdom
is no longer in the European Union
um and our officials are not meeting as
they used to meet which is true every
day there were working groups and there
were various groups and people talk
including in the erectus
um and in Westminster that we need new
institutions uh I want to touch in this
issue because we don't need any new
institutions in my view all we need to
do is to work the institutions that were
agreed on Good Friday so if I can just
make a few points on on this because I
think it's relevant and my one chance
I've been able to make this that it is
spotting I think the different
perspectives and that we all had to deal
with into making and agreeing and then
to delivering good Pride agreement as we
know the island was divided in 1922 to
propose
certainty to different tribes and
different cultures and and different
beliefs and a partition didn't create
those divisions but it certainly did
embed them and out of that came as
Society where different communities and
in different ways each felt besieged and
unbattled by the the other and the story
of the troubles which I always say
hardly
um explains the horror it conveys was
that the backdrop of all my political
Life as a young adult and young
politician in the 70s was remains at the
biggest thing that we have to deal with
but I think the New Perspective and the
profound and change that the Good Friday
agreement brought about was the breaking
true of unseemingly
um on breakable barrier is embedded
since partitioned and there could be a
parity esteem which was the big issue of
25 years ago for different traditions
and The Sovereign governments on these
islands and the political parties in
Northern Ireland and the International
Community and above all the people on
the island voted in in that referendum
of 25 years ago and they democratically
and endorse a profoundly changed future
that were beautifully different from the
past that preceded it and that future of
course has moved on we've had 25 years
of of Fairly perfect peace compared with
the 25 years that we'd seen before that
and the difference between those two
periods is is of course very much light
and dark and in the grind of politics
there is understandably frustration that
what was hope for has only been realized
partially or occasionally and I I
understand that a frustration but I also
have a sense of perspective at the 25
years as a golden era compared to what
was and could have been a more important
and convinced that what is to come is is
and it's very possible is better yet so
in the context of Irish history even in
the last hundred years since partition
at 25 years is a short time and we must
be a patient we must persevere and I
think as we celebrate
this year and as celebrate the the
pluses and the minuses of what has gone
over the period since the Good Friday
agreement was voted on by the people and
of course we have to look at what
happened in between the fact of of
brexit unimaginable in 1998 we discussed
everything in 1998 from a to a z and
back and up and down but nobody ever
mentioned uh that the United Kingdom
could possibly leave the European Union
if they did uh people would have
probably thought there were funny people
anyway but nobody did mention it but the
the work of this week I think is to
um and the work of last this day last
week was to bring the United Kingdom to
the end of of that period
um of what the arguments we've had since
2016 and uh I think the the contact
Stanford Northern Ireland is is
different in the UK outside the European
Union but determined of good working
relations with it the East-West
relationship between the United Kingdom
and Ireland has changed and there's
intense focus in getting the the
institutions back up and running uh in
this assembly and that's rightly so but
the future I foresee and the one
Provider from The Good Friday agreement
25 years ago is one what much deeper and
more Dynamic relations between the
Sovereign governments East and West
ironically the change contest provides a
dynamic for all of this to happen and
there is an essential Irish interest in
replacing the rich ecosystem of and
former British Irish relationships we
mutually enjoy Dundee my margins of our
shared EU business in Brussels the
British is ours Council has to be
reinvigorated and I especially welcome
the attendance of prime minister suneck
at its recent proceedings the first
prime minister to do so since Gordon
Brown
um over a decade ago and of course
United Kingdom itself has changed and
made important decisions for itself
about Evolution and there's a shared
community of interests across these
islands and in the context of a more
diverse Constitution arrangement in the
UK a shared Forum between the Sovereign
governments and the devolved
administrations make perfect sense so I
think it's time for us now to get and
use the institutions as we set out in
the agreement and particularly on the
east west the British Irish relationship
remains one of deep Mutual interests and
it's a far wider than Northern Ireland
if it proves to be in a hope it is that
the United Kingdom has reached the end
of the beginning of its departure
funding EU post-brexit it will
understandably want to capitalize by
normalizing its relations with Brussels
and in that context Ireland will be
important to the UK and rebuilding
relationships with the European Union
and we can be a good neighbor and a
friend to the UK and that was the
purpose of the the whole purpose of the
East West institutions that we
established under the good right
agreement and their context now that
nobody visits then their utility
importance would seem to be far greater
than ever and would urge people to take
an interest in in developing that area
which was not treated very seriously and
I won't go into blaming anybody but just
say it was not treated seriously over
the last two decades we have a shared
interest in in many areas I mentioned
last week about the north Seas energy
cooperation but there's so many other
areas where energy interconnectors and
so many other areas can we do we can
deal with these issues so I do believe
the work that you participate in here
and building up the East West will have
an enormous and important part to play
can I just mention uh briefly
at two other points if if I can
um the international
reporting process
um Commission of Engagement
um which is the IRC report I've been
reading that recently and it it
highlights uh many important issues uh
one area I just like to stress to all of
uh The Honorable members of of this
assembly uh is as that work around the
engagement with paramilitaries it is a
fact of life in this divided society
that there is
unfinished work to do we're dealing with
paramilitaries we've seen an event
recently in in Oma but the far wider
process I want to just address for a
second there is it is a fact of life the
paramilitarism and the structure for the
paramilitarism are still are still there
here and the IRC report if you get a
chance of those who may not have looked
at it and they make very interesting
points about that there should be a
process of continuing the dialogue with
these groups and to try
um to bring it to a a particular
role to where we will see the end of
them uh there are very good Mitch and
Reese who is the American representative
of John Cabernet and Tim O'Connor Monica
McWilliams who give their time and that
group have outlined in very clear terms
of the necessity for the resources and
the effort and the commitment of
politicians and the commitments of the
governments to deal with this issue
unfortunately it has drifted on 25 years
ago we taught that this would be a
matter that had not concluded I'm not
here to denounce any of the efforts or
the work I didn't engagement of what
goes on in paramilitaries that's not the
point I'm making I'm making a point that
in the normal society we have to work to
where they're no longer there where
they're no longer part of society or
where they're no longer a part of what
happens and it is a fact as they point
out in their engagement
and that the paramilitary structures are
still there
um some paramilitaries have moved away
and are gone and and that's in the story
and people have moved on with their
lives or into politics but there are
structures and engagements where that
hasn't happened and in quite a
sophisticated way they set it out in
their research and I think it is an area
so rather than I'm not into business
condemning it and into the business of
asking people to help and to work and
resource so that these issues can be
dealt with whether it's community
policing whether it's new as structures
of neighborhoods but it is an area that
has been left for for quite a
considerable time and the four or five
pages of the report
um if you read that you read a report of
of the the IRC I think is 20 to 25 you
will see
um what they're suggesting and they've
made recommendations to the government
and it's been discussed recently at the
intergovernmental conference so it is a
very important issue my last Point
um it would be wrong not to say
something about the the present position
I keep a close uh interest in everything
from the backstop to the to the protocol
uh to where we are uh now with the The
Windsor framework and needless to say I
wish that well
um I I have argued long over the winter
in in many programs that there were
issues to be addressed and that was a
fair argument and for unionism to make
the case that the UK internal economy
was something that they should be able
to deal with without the European Union
oversight into it
um I've also made the arguments last
year earlier last year about the issues
to do with
medicines and about some of the state
aidroads and the bathrobes and but as as
I read it and understand it and I think
everyone has had a chance
um it was a mouthful of documents or
when you analyze I am watching the
documents which I've had a chance of
reading fully
um if you look at the five or six issues
that we spoke about for the last few
years and God's moving from GB to
Northern Ireland a customs-based
approach based on whether goods are
staying in Northern Ireland or moving
into the single Market the farmer will
benefit from an expanded trusted Trader
scheme which dramatically simplified
procedures and drastically simplified
declarations with reduced data
requirements on the SPs and the
agri-food retail products for end
consumption Northern Ireland would be
able to move with minimal certification
requirements and controls physical
checks will follow a risk-based approach
there's additional safeguards including
label labeling the special Arrangements
applied for movements of pets plants and
Seed Potatoes which is an issue kept
coming up in debates their substantial
facilitation for moving Parcels about
business the customer business to
business
customer to business
with the last been entirely exempt from
Customs procedures there's a permanent
solution on medicines ensuring Northern
aren't access to all medicines including
novel medicines at the same time to GB
new flexibilities and that including the
ability to seek UK that rates below
minimum for removal Goods with no risks
resolution of issues associated with the
tarot break quotas for steel and
clarification of application of State
rules there are other safeguards as well
I think these have been the main points
that we have been across my
congratulations to the negotiations and
congratulations to
Marcus kovich answer prime minister
Rishi zunek and it seems to me on any
Fair examination that the main points
have been dealt with of course there are
always people who and people rightly
look at these things and want to see
um Dr clarifications and people
understand it but hopefully in the in
the short term and nobody wants to put
data in these things but in the short
term these issues can be uh wrapped up
we've had a a long debate now for
several years really since Theresa May
made the Lancaster house speech in
January 2017 when she stated that not
alone was UK pulling out at a single
Market was pulling out at the custom
Union which was a surprise at that day
we've dealt with those issues but six
years later
and my reading of the issues and from I
can say personally the issues that I was
making as I taught were Fair points on
behalf of unionism that those issues
have been comprehensively dealt with and
hopefully we can successfully uh move on
and move on to a position where we can
see the institutions of the Good Friday
and set up whether that happens in a
week or a month is really irrelevant but
the sooner the better where politicians
will again be able to to move so I want
to wish everybody well in those
discussions and hopefully we can bring
it out to a finality my last point is to
say to you good politicians my
admiration is always to my previous
profession to all of you is that work so
hard for the people politics never gets
any easier it seems to be more difficult
some sometimes even more trivial I don't
know how you deal with some of the
issues you have to deal with
um I think if we had had uh social media
back when we were negotiating I had a
good Friday agreement I think John
Taylor would probably agree with me it
would have been a bit difficult John and
to do that it was hard enough to keep
everyone locked up in Castle buildings
but we managed I think
um to to deal with issues but you have
to deal with it and a more difficult
world I know that they presser is pro
politicians as they always were but
um I I I I I wish you well in all the
tasks that you have to deal with and I I
do
um salute you for your determination to
make things better to make Society
better which is what politics is about I
congratulate all the parties you
represent for the effort they put into
politics and trying to make life better
and I do acknowledge all of you in
whatever way you helped to negotiate to
see the Good Friday agreement true that
that is something that we can all be
eternally happy with it was the work of
of many hands I was honored to be
teaching at the time worked with Tony
Blair and work with so many other
politicians but the one thing I found
was across all the parties that was a
tremendous
commitment at making peace on this
island and to work with Secretary of
State Paul Murphy to to see the progress
that was made and all zadasca is to have
to keep on working to make sure it is a
process it's never over what we do is we
celebrate the 25-year since we
negotiated but I'd ask you to maintain
the same vigilance that's necessary
because there won't be a day where you
can say it's complete the work continues
so thank you very much
foreign
for your very comprehensive outline of
the negotiations leading up to the
agreement in April 1998 and also to the
working of the Good Friday agreement in
the meantime one phrase that you used
among the many phrases that struck me
was what was hope for all has only been
partially realized I think the theme of
our clean recession is very much
building on the success of what has been
achieved and look into the next period
ahead as well so it's very much in in in
sync with your own thoughts here today
and your encouragement because the
Ireland that we have today is is
transformed what it was pre The Good
Friday agreement and as you said
birthday to you and all the others who
made that possible as a society and as
Islands we are eternally grateful for
that good work and we will take
questions from the floor after the next
speaker
thank you very much Brendan and I'm
delighted to welcome sir John Holmes
here today so John was principal private
secretary to both Sir John Major and Sir
Tony Blair during their premierships and
was knighted in the 1999 New Year honors
for services to peace in Northern
Ireland he has since had a distinguished
career of Public Service as an
ambassador to Portugal and then to
France as emergency relief coordinator
for the United Nations and as chair of
the United Kingdom's electoral
commission so John could I now call on
you to give your address
[Applause]
well thank you very much indeed for the
opportunity to speak to you today on
about the significance of the Good
Friday agreement it's a bit hard for me
to follow bertia Hearn to be honest
clearly I should be Tony Blair but
obviously for better for worse I'm not
so you'll have to make do with me
um
it's also a bit difficult to say
anything new or original about an iconic
event such as a good Friday agreement I
mean so many millions of words have been
spoken or written about it and will be
in the next couple of months and I'm
sure I won't succeed in saying anything
original and I apologize for that I also
apologize for speaking very much from
the perspective of of Downing Street uh
over these events and paying
correspondingly less attention to the
roles of the many other people who made
peace possible from from elsewhere
Bertie has already mentioned many of
them especially those no longer with us
and I salute them all fully even if I
don't mention in what I'm going to say
mention them explicitly
so why am I here I mean I uh I'm not a
Northern Ireland expert well I was
closely involved in the run-up to the
Good Friday agreement and its immediate
aftermath
after I became John Major's overseas
advisor in January 1966 1996 I should
say I'm not that old
um I mean my role covered everything in
down the street related to foreign
policy defense and overseas aid but also
and rather oddly in some ways you might
think Northern Ireland
I think the main logic was that
historically much of the activity of the
of the post had been about relations
with the Irish Republic and the U.S but
in any case I quickly discovered that
Northern Irish Affairs and particularly
the peace process occupied a very
substantial portion of my time probably
sometimes up to half of it even though I
had no shortage of other things to do
my part in all this under Blair as well
as major was multiple if you like in
addition to being an advisor I was the
main link between the Northern Ireland
office and Downing Street the high level
interlocutory with the with the U.S
government who were very interested
obviously the chief contact with the
tissue's office in Dublin and last but
not least an interlocutor on behalf of
the Prime Minister with the main
Northern Ireland parties when they
didn't want to go through the Northern
Ireland office
and this last role was particularly
important for the unionists
who had long suspected the Northern
Ireland office have been too close to
Dublin to green and simply not to be
trusted and they're therefore specially
valued the link that I and others were
able to provide with Downing Street
obviously they always wanted to talk to
the Prime Minister himself if they could
but in the absence of that they wanted
to talk to me or later with Jonathan
Powell attorney Blair chief of staff
now my own time in number 10 started
rather inauspiciously in February 1996
as you'll remember the provisional Ira
broke the ceasefire which had been in
place since 1994 by setting off a bomb
in the city of London against the
background of all the long-running and
difficult arguments about the
decommissioning of weapons and the
failure to start all party talks
but to his great credit and I think and
in line with a huge personal effort he'd
already put in to make peace possible
John Major did not take what might have
been the easy way out by in effect
abandoning peace efforts until after the
next election which he could have done
especially considering his own slim
majority at the time and troubles with
members of his own party
instead he just he restarted the
painstaking process of trying to build a
Way Forward again trying to rebuild the
trusts which have been lost during the
ceasefire and its abrupt ending and I
think that despite unpromising
circumstances false steps setbacks
during those next few months some
progress was still made for example we
had the start after the controversial
election of a constituent body of
multi-party talks despite the absence
from them at that point of shin Fein
but still by late 1966 no
it's right in a minute 1996 it was clear
that substantive progress would have to
await the arrival of a new government
after the UK elections in May 1997 and
attention on all sides switched to
preparing for that
and somewhat unusually I was asked to
stay in my role by in Downing Street by
Tony Blair the incoming prime minister
because uh that was I was able to
provide some continuity
he arrived determined to take full
advantage of his large majority in the
area of Northern Ireland as elsewhere
and to move things on as quickly as
possible
in a way that John Major had ultimately
simply not been able to do
many of you may recall his speech in
Belfast shortly after he became prime
minister he reassured the unionist that
he was not a Persuader for unification
and did not expect to see any such thing
in his lifetime all that if anyone else
in the room
but he also made an offer to Shin Fein
to join the talks quickly as long as
they renewed their ceasefire and
accepted the six Mutual principles of
commitment to Peaceful Democratic
discussion and renunciation of violence
otherwise in the words of what became a
much overused cliche the Peace Train
would have to leave without them
to cut a long and difficult and
convoluted stories short and most of you
know it already
but they did renew the ceasefire in July
1997 and said enough about the Mitchell
principles to join the talks in
September indecently quickly I have to
say some thought at the time
so the stage was set for the
intensification of the talks with a
deadline of May 1998 which ultimately
led to the Good Friday agreement some
seven months later
as Bertie herner said that period was
not exactly a smooth process and
progress at times seemed glacial if not
in Reverse but we did get there in the
end
and along the way Blair was able to do
something important I think which made
you would have liked to do but could not
do politically which was to meet the
shin Fein leadership in person that was
a huge media story as those of you
around at the time will remember when it
first happened but something and there's
a lesson there somewhere which quickly
became accepted as normal routine
now this highly abbreviated description
of the lead-up to the Good Friday
agreement makes its agreement sound
almost achievement sound almost simple
and inevitable and perhaps it does feel
that way to some people who weren't
involved as they looked back at it from
now 25 years later
but I want to be clear that it was
neither of those things it was not
simple and it was not inevitable and it
was in many many ways I think a miracle
that we got there
that process could easily have been
derailed at almost any moment and nearly
was several times in those final months
weeks and even days
it was also of course very much the
final outcome of Decades of patient and
difficult work to narrow gaps reduce
suspicions draft endless techs and
identify possible ways forward and these
had continued under successive Prime
Ministers with landmarks along the way
such as the anglo-warish agreement
astonishingly concluded by Mrs Thatcher
the Downing Street decoration and the
Frameworks document John Major did make
a massive contribution to this towards
the end through his own determination to
keep trying and his work with successive
t-shirts in Dublin
and I think final success was only
possible at all because the Stars had
aligned in a rare way
key parts of the Republican political
leadership had concluded that they
needed a political deal to prevent their
children having to fight the same
battles as they'd spent their life on
the British government concluded that
there was no lasting security solution
available
the Irish government had wanted a deal
and was even prepared to amend its
Constitution to achieve it the two main
political parties at the time the Ulster
unionists and the sdlp were in different
ways and to different degrees ready to
find a power sharing agreement
the leaders in Dublin London and
Washington gone on well and they wanted
to make something happen
the talks process had struck Lucky in
finding in George Mitchell the perfect
chair
the population was fed up with violence
and wanted a more normal life
these were vital but potentially
transitory conditions
and it's worth thinking about why Tony
Blair would in the end
able to build so successfully on all the
work that John Major had done
it was not that their underlying views
or attitudes or approaches differed in
any substantial way
so I would single out several factors
first of all the political strength and
authority of a large majority in the
expectation even at that early stage
that Blair would serve at least two
terms
SO waiting for his successor would have
meant waiting at least 10 years so this
was a powerful incentive for the
Northern Ireland parties and indeed the
Irish government to do or deal with him
if at all possible
secondly the absence within its own
labor party of any significant
opposition to his policies on Northern
Ireland and the weakened position
politically of conservative politicians
who were traditionally uneasy about
where the talks were likely to go
thirdly he's willingness like that of
John major before him to invest huge
amounts of time energy and political
Capital into the search for peace in
Northern Ireland even knowing that the
domestic political dividends in the rest
of Great Britain for doing so were small
to non-existent
fourthly his ability to talk to all
sides and to persuade them that he had
their best interests at best interests
at heart even if this meant saying
different things to different people at
different times and saying sailing
rather close to the wind at times
and finally his close relationship with
bertia Hearn and the statesmanship shown
by Bertier and throughout the process
I'm not saying that just because he's
here Antonio Bear's ability also to
channel the close interest of Bill
Clinton in useful directions at critical
moments
despite all these positive forces at
work I repeat that the Good Friday
agreement was no foregone conclusion
lack of trust in the run-up was endemic
the irreconcilable differences over
decommissioning of paramilitary weapons
and the possibility of renewed violence
hung over everything
and from a British point of view this
always seemed to me the most toxic and
difficult issue how do you deal with
political violence in a democracy
is it right to seem to reward violence
isn't it reasonable to demand a
definitive end to violence and the
renunciation
moment thanks to some hastily cobbled
together reassurances from us
encouragement from Bill Clinton and
statesmanship from David Trimble and
others
and they continued to worry that somehow
they'd lost out in this process even
though they'd won their most important
demand of acceptance by all concerned of
the principle of consent
control of the narrative in what was
almost always and perhaps remains seen
as a zero-sum game was vital and lack of
it almost scuppered the subsequent
referendum in the North
so agreement at the time seemed like a
miracle and to me looking back it still
does
now obviously as many people here know
only too well and as Bertie has talked
about the Good Friday agreement was not
the end of the arguments but simply the
beginning of a whole series of old ones
and some new ones
my own role finished in Spring 99 but
years of Crisis Summits and knife edge
talks followed to try to get past lack
of progress on decommissioning
north-south Corporation how the
institution should operate and to try
and get the institutions to function as
they were intended to
implementation was nothing like what we
had imagined at the time and of course
we are in many ways still going around
that track
but that's another story
so how can we sum up what the Good
Friday agreement signified
his biggest success was obviously in
bringing a lasting period of peace to
Northern Ireland and there has been a
transformation in the lives of most of
its people in terms of their ability to
get on with their lives without fear
that alone I think is Success enough for
most political agreements of this kind
there is of course a lot more
decommissioning did eventually happen
though it took far longer than anyone
could possibly have anticipated and the
arguments about how much it really
mattered continue
the Royal also constabulary was
transformed as we've heard into the
Northern Ireland Police Service
discrimination on religious ground has
reduced if not disappeared
the Stormont institutions have worked
well at times who would ever have
imagined in 1970 1997 certainly not me
seeing Ian Paisley and Martin McGinnis
governing together
at the same time a lot of what we hoped
and imagined at the time of the Good
Friday agreement has not happened
much of the unionist and nationalist
communities still largely exist in
parallel and mutually hostile universes
the two mainstream parties which had
gone the extra mile to conclude the deal
the sdlp and the Ulster unions were
rejected by the electorate in favor of
the dup and shin Fein education remains
largely segregated politics remains
largely tribal and trust between leaders
is low to put it no stronger
we had hoped at the time that the
politicians of Northern Ireland could
stop aiming so many of their speeches at
the UK and international audiences and
get down to fixing the hospitals of the
schools but the Constitutional issues
still Loom largest over everything
expectations were naive given the
history
in any case progress towards a more
integrated and harmonious Society has
without doubt been painfully slow
attitudes in the younger generation give
grounds for renewed hope for the future
and I hope that's what comes to pass but
too many still seem to cling on to the
same old tropes heard from their parents
actual is to ask what would have
happened if we had not succeeded in
reaching agreement on Good Friday 25
years ago
the short and obvious answer is that we
would have gone back to working away at
it in the hope of doing better next time
the May 1998 deadline was always
artificial even though in the end it did
concentrate mines that had been hoped
I don't think we'd have gone back to the
drawing board
The Good Friday agreement was already in
many ways the Shameless Mallon famously
put it Sunningdale for slow learners
the wheel didn't need to be reinvented
and perhaps that would have worked in
time that underlying desire for peace
would have pushed all sides into another
try
but there would have been nothing
inevitable about this and about success
unionists Loyalists and Republicans
might have concluded in their own ways
that the other side was irredeemably
hopeless and incapable of making the
necessary compromises
the souring of relations amid the
unavoidable recrimination and blame
games after such a failure could have
complicated A Renewed peace process for
years
if violence had restarted it would not
easily have been stopped again at least
not quickly
the alignment of stars as I've talked
about and The Coincidence of compatible
personalities might well not have
recurred any times quickly
the Readiness of some of the principles
to put other things on hold and to
continue to give vast amounts and time
and effort to The elusive search for
peace in Northern Ireland could
certainly not have been guaranteed
look at what's happened in the Middle
East and efforts to solve the
Palestinian dispute
it's based on a two-state solution was
very close 25 years ago but the deal
could not be closed because some of the
principles found it easier to say no and
preferred not to confront their own
supporters and likely to be disappointed
maybe furious with the compromises
they'd made
now 25 years later any kind of lasting
settlement for the Palestinian problems
looks as far away as it ever has and
worse no one is even really trying
so for the Good Friday agreement to be
reached the day had to be seized and it
was just
one lesson for Northern aligned I think
hardly an original one but an
appropriate one for this Gathering is
that its peace and prosperity are best
assured when the British and Irish
governments worked together harmoniously
even if their interests and Views are
never likely to be exactly the same
and that's particularly the case when
the government in Washington is also
pushing in the same direction without
interfering too much
in the end have to be the ones who make
peace and move forward
but they often need help to do so
brexit has made such cooperation more
complex and more difficult in Northern
Ireland in many ways
but it's also made it more necessary not
less I Echo very strongly what Bertie at
Hearn was saying about this in his own
remarks
the point is that without the
Cooperative relationship between London
and Dublin
each Capital trying to bring along and
reassure the parties closest to them
with all the complexities and problems
that brought for both of us the Good
Friday agreement could never have
happened
there were still lots of rails and
misunderstandings even during the good
periods
each side often thought the other was
exaggerating the difficulties they were
having with those they were working with
but that habit of working together and
the underlying trust built up over the
years
enhanced by the Hearn relationship I've
talked about just got us through
I suspect this could only be managed
between two mature democracies and
bureaucracies
in the end both sides despite the
difficulties were able to keep their
eyes on the bigger picture and The Wider
goal and overcome their often
conflicting instincts and emotions
are there wider lessons for the world
from what happened in Belfast 25 years
ago
there have been many attempts to
transfer the lead the learnings to other
contexts I've been involved in some for
example in Burma Myanmar most have not
really borne fruit
if the truth is to be told
certainly the particular circumferences
of Northern Ireland are not replicated
elsewhere
nevertheless I believe there is a vital
need to use again the example of
Northern Ireland in today's world
the International Community whatever
those words now mean seems to have lost
the Knack of solving difficult problems
and producing peace and has lost even
the will to tackle them
nationalism is the order of the day and
the great powers are too busy competing
with each other to cooperate even when
it's manifestly in their own interests
conflicts are left to Fester
and fester they certainly do
protagonists protagonists who are never
going to be able to solve their problems
without a significant degree of outside
help on and pressure on not getting
either
the result is discouraging for the world
and appalling for the civilian
populations who are always and
inevitably the ones who suffer most
the lesson is not that peacemaking is
easy or usually rewarded it most
definitely is not
but success is possible and always worth
investing in
yes the stars or enough of them need to
align there has to be some Readiness on
the part of the struggling parties to
accept that continuing violence and
intransigence will not get them what
they want
they have to be actors who are ready to
invest large amounts of time and effort
to bridge gaps to find compromises not
to take no for an answer and who are
ready to risk their own reputations
and if the right day does arrive the
moment has to be seized when the
opportunity is there it might not recur
and we also have to accept that any deal
is not likely to resolve all the
problems as it has not in Northern
Ireland and has it as it has not for
example in the Balkans following the
hard one date and peace agreement of the
1990s
but such problems can be tackled with
much more hope of success if there is at
least peace as a basic background
and if no one is even trying to make
peace the prospects are Bleak indeed
we got lucky in Northern Ireland our
success is needed and need to stay lucky
especially in the contentious context of
brexit
we knew when we did the Good Friday deal
that there would always be likely to be
some people not ready to accept the
compromises and ready to go back to
violence
we have indeed seen that albeit in a
very minor way and we continue to do so
as events of recent weeks have proved
but the key to success in beating such
people is that they need to be and
obviously out of touch and out of line
small minority
not a group able to swim in a sea of
wider popular support
I think that is the lasting achievement
and significance of the Good Friday
agreement
but even that cannot be taken for
granted the struggle against extremism
and for reconciliation has to be
constant
and they're Readiness to keep trying
even when the prospects for Success look
Bleak must be there that is also the
significance of the Good Friday
agreement as we markets 25 years thank
you very much
foreign
for an absolutely excellent
speech and and thoughts for all of us to
consider you talked about being lucky
and the Stars aligned but it was quite
clear that luck was actually the hard
work that went into uh or all of this
from everybody who was so determined and
if it hadn't been for all that hard work
those Stars could never have aligned
um I'm also struck by the point about
that really actually from Bertie as well
this is a process not an event that
actually that agreement that Monumental
agreement 25 years ago which did
transform lives but there's so much more
that needs to be achieved and that's
something that we as an assembly need to
think very hard about about what we can
do to help that process continue and I
suppose my final reflection on
everything you've said is that you said
it's easier to say no and that's true
but leadership is doing difficult things
even if they're not necessarily popular
and that leadership is what we saw in
1998 we saw it across the board from
everybody the Stars may have aligned
that everyone was prepared to show that
leadership but that hard work and the
work that you and Bertie and all that
team did is something we should all
reflect on so thank you so much for
giving your time we have about 10
minutes for questions and lord bew
caught my eye some time ago so I'm going
to start with you Paul
sound is that not right
first of all I'd like to Echo the thanks
both to Sir John Holmes and two parties
excellent presentations
I don't really disagree with the word
there is one thing uh that I I would
like to tease out a bit more and to ask
does the drama with John particularly
dwelt on and I'm now looking at John
Taylor lauten Clooney the drama of the
40-foot bar barge Pole
um which many people have been going to
read week said that's it it's over
it's not not you know this this is not
going to happen this agreement does does
that does that drama and I I know that
John's views on that the subject of
notes I've got for many years before
that were actually very subtle and well
informed so I knew the the you know some
of the complexity of the thinking behind
that moment but is it the drama in
itself
which actually has has a role in in in
in in in making the thing move forward
in other words
is there something about that moment
something about the decision by the then
teacher to modify the Irish negotiating
position which somehow in human terms
connects the dad teacher with the soon
to be first minister of Northern Ireland
and at some level not something you'd
ever planned for not something that John
holmesan number 10 said let's have a
drama let's have a document that goes a
bit too far and we all talk ourselves
back from that just as a matter of
accidental political drama in some way
make the whole project of the good
project at the end of that week much
firmer and much stronger and of course
the key thing there is the decision by
the then t-shirt to to be flexible and
to think what is really true which is
what our real Ireland's real interests
then because Ireland's real interests
were instability on the island of
Ireland above all and in the settlement
that Northern nationalists could could
live with and he it's clear that he got
it right so I was kind of moved to just
reflect on just the significance of a
totally unexpected political drama
especially in the presence of some of
the main agents lordship Clooney and the
teacher but totally unexpectedly go and
actually not only not knocking it off
the road the project of the agreement
but actually making the agreement in
human terms more and that's what does
ultimately matter more real and stronger
that thank you thank you Lord view can I
ask John Answer John and Bertie could
you perhaps come and sit at the front
here if you don't mind I've got a few
people who've caught my eye and I'm very
conscious that we are we I do have to
finish at 11. so can I bring in Colin
McGrath and then Lord kill Clooney and
then we'll let you respond to those
three points
Sheldon's installment and Belfast and um
I would like to acknowledge being in
this room I've been in MLA for nearly
seven years and only for three of those
years has this room actually sat as an
assembly so it is a bit of a novel place
to be today and I want to begin by
thanking birdie and John and others that
are here today that played their part in
the Good Friday agreement
as it reached its culmination I was
concluding my University degree uh and
that was a degree that included a
placement that had to be rearranged for
a few miles from here because one
terrorist organization decided that it
simply wanted to shoot Catholics and
therefore I had to be removed out of
that estate and conclude my placement
somewhere else so the work of the Good
Friday agreement obviously brought a lot
more stability here that enabled me to
progress and others of my generation but
the two points that I would like to ask
questions about first obviously from the
grid Friday agreement it's recognition
that we need to make some changes to it
I believe some of the changes that were
made in the Saint Andrews agreement have
created many of the difficulties that we
are currently facing and I think some of
that damage needs to be undone and we
need to see more changes but I wonder
just if you have a view about some of
the changes that you would like to see
and given and I'm afraid we're going to
have to keep a record of this given that
we don't actually have any
representatives of the dup here do you
have any advice for them as they
approach the decisions that they have to
take in the next few weeks thank you
we're not standing up
at uh
first of all
it's great to be sitting in the same
seat
that I used to sit on
when I was Catholic Ministry for home
Affairs and all around
and this is the first time I've been
back in this building for 51 years
I was in the Ulster hospital just up the
road
and Brian Faulkner demanded I should
come here to address ten thousand people
outside Stormwind
I know the hospital said I was allowed
out for four hours
because I just read the subject of an
assassination attempt by the ra
anyway
I want to pay tribute to bertia Hearn
to Tony Blair
to Paul Murphy they're the ones who
really did the hard work
that brought about the Belfast agreement
and I don't think that is accurately
recorded by Young journalists in their
20s today
who weren't even born 25 years ago and
don't know who was important and who
wasn't important but they certainly were
and I appreciate it especially Tony
Blair in the midst of the
Iraqi War gave more time to Northern
Ireland
I was amused when Sir John mentioned the
Middle East
because I remember bringing the Belfast
agreement to
Ramallah to give a copy to Arafat and
said here's the basis in which you
should get an agreement between
Palestine and Israel it hasn't happened
and
as as one who opposes a United Ireland
I do remember the very first day the
meeting took place of the Belfast
agreement talks
on the chairmanship George Mitchell
and at storm not in this building and he
said
I want us to agree an agenda
and for some reason David Trimble
was unable to attend and as his Deputy
he said John I want you to lead the
Union's delegation of the talks
and I jumped up to Sinister Mitchell
who's a Maronite and my solicitor was a
Maronite which gave us a close
relationship
and I said to him
you can hardly cooperate with another
country size of your border I live near
the border I came there this morning
if they don't even recognize it how can
you talk to people who say you don't
exist
and so I said the first thing on the
agenda must be the recognition of
Northern Ireland as part of the United
Kingdom
the then former minister of the Republic
of Ireland David Andrews jumped up and
said no way will that happen no way
should that be on the agenda
so he was not in favor of recognition at
that time
and I stood up in front of Senator
Mitchell said
sorry that's fundamental
I'm now taking the Elsa Union's
delegation out of the talks
and that was very serious on the very
first day of the talks which ended up
with the Belfast agreement
and Mitchell said right
but stay in the building
so we stayed in the building all day
from 10 o'clock in the morning until
five o'clock in the afternoon when
Mitchell called us back
and he said Dublin has now reconsidered
their position and that can be on the
agenda and that was the beginning of
movement which leads the Belfast
agreement
now actually one who opposes United
Ireland I say to our Irish friends who
are here today
who have a great belief and want a
United Art
have you ever thought of what it means
to you
I want 30 in particular to answer this
one it would mean the arrival of 1
million Brits
in the so-called New Republic of Ireland
one million Brits and they would hold 15
seats in dollars
and there would have to be a coalition
of Brits from northern in the government
of the Republic
and those Brits would therefore be
ruling Kerry and Cork and places like
that
How the Irish really thought this out
because I think there's a rich
call for United Isle but the Irish never
think it out of what means to them
that's my question to Bertie
would you like some more questions to be
put before you respond
well thanks very much first of all the
uh
the question on the the north south
bodies
um Lord Butte
um race
there have been a long discussion
um during the talks about the the areas
that would be suitable for uh North
South cooperation and there was a list
drawn up in in the Department of
Education of what those areas would be
um as I think a few people in this room
remember that that list was agreed with
the British government
so
we had concluded the discussion with the
British government that they they had
agreed on that but
then
the the case was made that listened
if we could get north south bodies set
up and get the structure in North
everybody set up and get it and Define
the number of areas
you know incrementally over time and
this is what happened there were many
areas like Cancers and maternity
services and other issues that
afterwards there was great cooperation
on that you didn't actually need to have
implementation uh bodies and of course
when Nora Cancun
mentions that um
uh that he wouldn't touch the whole
process with a 40-foot pole I I decided
that we we need to engage in more
comprehensive discussion and and come to
an agreement which we which we did and
uh David trimbled the late David Trimble
and I agree that list but it it was it
was a dividing point it was it was no
doubt about it we weren't going to make
much more uh progress and at that time
we were trying to get
and people will forget now uh I'll try
and be short about this but people
forget now that we we hadn't even agreed
then that it was going to be an assembly
uh it wasn't a unanimous view that we
should have an assembly in the
discussions but wasn't an unanimous view
we should have an executive uh it was
only
um Lord Murphy would remember it was
only late I think on the Thursday night
when we finally got to agreement between
the Ulster unionist party and the sdlp
that we would we would have uh we would
have that
um so that's that then I decided to move
and and to to change to change the
demand and to to to refine the
implementation bodies into into certain
areas which worked worked well
um I I had offered those for the
historical record in this way I had
offered that we we showed amalgamate
um the Ida and invest in Northern
Ireland as one of the the issues I
um that may not have been uh loved by
everybody at the time but
um and there was maybe some opposition
from Ida in Dublin as well to it now I
do think would have made a lot of sense
and I did to this day it was made a lot
of sense when you go on trade missions
and people will find this after brexit
when this assembly is back up and
running again
and speaker Masky made a point this
morning they're going to have to go out
to to to build up investment and trade
nobody ever really asked you know which
part of Ireland or when you went around
Silicon Valley and you were trying to
get investment uh it was the island of
Ireland so made eminent sense to have uh
all Island trade but anyway that wasn't
agreed at the time
um and the issue of changes
um your point and the changes my my
strong strong advice
um is that the institution should be up
and running
not to fall into the Trap
of having a debate about
um the reform
for the institutions are up and running
and the reason is that will not be any
changes unless there is the traces
across Community consent and you won't
get cross-community consent on most of
these issues so in the cold light a cool
light a day or the good lighter day I
think you can have a sensible discussion
about reform as we did in the Saint
Andrews in 2000 October 2006 but to try
and have that we'll delay the assembly
it'll be used for a delaying tactic for
dsmony so let the institutions be set up
as quickly as possible on the end of of
this current debate on the Windsor
agreement and then if there are areas
for reform let those issues but do not
do it the other way around it'll be
it'll be a fatal mistake believe me
um and it's not that I'm saying I think
cross community consent
uh should be used for everything it's
not done I'm saying that because I can
see arguments where it's not but if if
you're trying if you're trying to get
that agreement first it will delay the
institutions of
um on the question of I I moved from
when I was young I went to the United
Ireland uh John
um now now I want to now I want a new
Ireland uh and I want a new Ireland
where you know reasonable moderate
people like you I will be able to play a
key
we'll be able to play a key role in in
in in the New Ireland
um and that the 15 moderate unionists
that would be elected to Darling will
help to make that even a better place
than it is today
[Applause]
so I'd add a few words I'm certainly not
going to go near the third question
because it wasn't addressed to me
luckily
um on the first point I mean I think uh
Lord beer is right that it was
um a seminal moment because I you know I
do recall and I think I mentioned this
briefly and what I just said that
[Music]
first of all
agreeing to renegotiate those bodies and
secondly returning to Belfast from
doubling literally just after the
funeral of your mother was made a
profound impression as my my
recollection on the unionists because it
showed real Readiness to engage and to
compromise and to work for an agreement
and that I think did Infuse the rest of
those talks for the next few days so I
think it was a seminal moment even
though it started very inauspiciously I
mean just again for the historical
record
um
I had been part of negotiating the
framework for the north south
cooperation bodies not the list and I
was horrified when I saw the list which
was published which I'd been assured by
the Northern Ireland office at the time
was non-controversial
well that was not true but uh they were
brought back to a reasonable level
um although of course that was hardly
the end of the argument because many
years were spent on trying to get it
right after that
um on changes to the Good Friday
agreement I mean I don't really claim
any expertise I have not been involved
in any way in the process since 1999. I
think what I would say is that the Good
Friday agreement should not be regarded
as a gospel uh in where you can't change
any word whatever it status
um so I'm not I wouldn't be opposed in
principle to changing bits of it and
bits of it were effectively Changed by
subsequent agreements I think the more
important thing is is is what is
happening or what is being said or what
is being done in the spirit of that
agreement and the spirit of that
agreement was that every bit everybody
gave something everybody got something
nobody got everything they wanted and
that's what's what made it possible and
that's why it was miraculous in some
ways
um you know so you'd need to have that
Spirit now as you had then if you're
going to move forward and that's more
important than the the details of
whether well that's what it says you
know in the Good Friday agreement or in
the center Andrews agreement so we can't
go back on that that to me that's a bit
like you know governing from the the
dictates of the Bible which was written
in a completely different context and
not taking into account modern events
but the spirit is is uh I would say the
most important thing and that needs to
be there too
thank you as you can see we've not
stopped at 11 o'clock as it's always the
way in the British Irish parliamentary
assembly there's much interest I'm going
to take four final questions if you can
keep them short that would be
appreciated and then we will let our
speakers
um go back on uh to the whatever
important stuff they've got for the rest
of the day but I've got Kate nickel Neil
o'donoghy reg MP and John lahart
thank you chair and thank you so much uh
so John mentioned
um buddy O'Hearn uh going to his
mother's funeral during the negotiations
and I think this is a moment that has
been lost a lot in in recounting of it
and the personal sacrifices that so many
people made but especially you and I
want to pay tribute to you and thank you
for all the work that you both did
um my name is Kate Nichol I'm an
alliance at MLA and I was elected in May
so this is my first time having a debate
in this chamber that is not to elect a
speaker I nurture comments
um around reform and I respectfully
disagree uh the fact that we have been
in here six times to nominate a speaker
and we have not had one because it
required cross-community consent and my
party the cross community parties votes
do not count within that to me is very
clear that we do need to reform this if
the dup do not come back into the
assembly would you not agree that
reforming the institutions to willing
majority willing Coalition is the way
forward to get the assembly up and
running because political uncertainty
will continue to escalate without stable
government thank you
thank you co-chairs and thanks to our
our guests uh today
um I had intended to ask a question
about the old Ireland bodies and I
didn't realize it would
sort of gather this sort of interest in
advance but
um I would hope uh that with the wisdom
of yours and hopefully it's not too much
to ask that the Lord called Clooney
would appreciate now that the all artem
bodies actually are positive uh and uh
dealing with the Fallout of issues like
the dreaded b word brexit when you look
at the impact of the pandemic across the
island
um that there's no finer example uh in
Ireland than our rugby team have shown
that when Ireland works best it works as
one
um so what we actually need Bertie I
think is in the context of looking at
the re-establishment of the Good Friday
agreement apparatus and institutions uh
a firm view on the significance and the
importance of the existing all Ireland
bodies but also as the world changes
around owners because I agree with you
absolutely that this forum provides us
with a really important East-West
opportunity for engagement but by virtue
of its makeup it also allows for a
really important strand too north-south
engagement between the assembly and and
the Iraqis so from your perspective
because I think it's important that this
assembly doesn't sound a message that
somehow are existing all Ireland bodies
are contentious or controversial they're
not
um we need more of them and that's the
last of the last 25 years so where would
you envisage that we could grow that
cooperation on an all-ireland basis as
hopefully the institutions are
re-established and how important do you
think it is for the Irish government to
act as a driver because it's important
to remember that the all Ireland bodies
work both ways and they benefit everyone
from carry to Darry guremiah thank you
uh chair I
would just want to make a point about
the old Ireland bodies it wasn't the
crisis arose not because of the areas of
uh influence that they would have had it
was because the proposal that was made
in the initial draft was to give them
all Island executive parts
which meant that they would operate
freely without the consent
or accountability to this assembly and
to the door so it wasn't so much the
areas of cooperation it was the fact
that they would have had executive
powers and that
was the point of John's barge pool for
which he's been maligned because he was
right and not there was no argument
amongst our delegation it was just a
showstopper
and I have to say had birthday not come
back from waking his mother to fix that
there'd be no deal I can assure you it
was as simple as that
so
um the other point I would make is
reform
there are mechanisms in the agreement
for review
I mean when we negotiated we weren't
stupid that nothing lasts forever and
you have to do that but I would point
out gently point out the kid that her
party
negotiated it and went to the people and
recommended in a referendum as always as
we all did so we can't do bits and
pieces
to suit a particular point at a
particular time and I think bertie's
advice is right there's a way of doing
it it's an old party agreement it's not
agreement between two governments and
therefore the parties have to sit down
and deal with it in the processes that
are provided for in the agreement
and I would also make the final point
we are celebrating our commemorating an
agreement 25 years ago but the agreement
we have operating today is not the
agreement we negotiated
it is not the agreement that went to a
referendum it has been amended
and uh Colin McGrath we had reference to
that the mechanism for electing first
minister is why we're in trouble
because what the government said and
this is the one thing I disagree with
Bertie and Tony Blair they rewarded the
people who didn't negotiate strand one
because neither do you pierce
participated in those negotiations and
subsequently they
changed the rules ironically
so that instead of having
cross-community consent in a joint
resolution for first and Deputy first
minister in this chamber it became just
the largest party
irrespective of designation and whatever
you may feel about the designation the
point of that negotiation was to show
that it was a genuine partnership and no
section the community could operate
without the consent of the other
so we had a joint veto awkward but
necessary to bring people together to
sit in this building when many
nationalists wouldn't have gone put a
foot in it
for many many years now that was taken
away to fix a particular political
problem and I think that is why we've
had all these years of difficulty
because what we were envisaging when we
negotiated that is we could bring in to
get people focused more on economically
driven politics rather than on the
Constitutional every subsequent election
was a and Paisley would say if you don't
vote for me you get Martin McGinnis I've
held the office there is no difference
you couldn't send a letter out of the
department without both people agreeing
to it the mistake we made was the names
and how we what we call it we were
looking at what was happening in
Scotland at that time where they were
having a first Minister but that was
probably an error so I'd like to ask our
panelists whether they consider that an
issue and I would just wanted to make it
clear that cross-border bodies I was
instrumental in establishing two of them
intertrade Ireland tourism Ireland
they're fine there's nothing wrong with
them they can perhaps be adapted to try
and fix the mess we're currently at
and use the agreement to fix things
instead of trying to imagine new ones
but I would simply be interested in the
response of our guests thank you
thanks chair
um
and thanks to Sir John and Bertie
particularly want to acknowledge
bertie's presence today as my former
party leader and former t-shirt and
what's a particularly
difficult day for him that you might not
be aware of he's an avid Manchester
United fan
so it took a lot of courage to come and
speak to us and we appreciate it
um
please say nothing sure
let that one pass
um
just to reassure or to to respond to to
Lord kraklooney and it's a privilege to
be with him today
um as well as an Irish Republican from
the final fall tradition I would say to
you you know coming from a country that
was colonized and ruled for 800 years by
what we would have regarded as a foreign
power of the idea of sharing power with
fairly fellow countrymen and women
um is a much more attractive proposition
than what was endured heretofore
um and to follow on
um
to what Bertie said in relation to you
know in New Ireland I think this body
should be aware that there is a much
more mature debate and discussion going
on on this island in relation to its
future there was a time and I I'm a
little younger than Bertie but not too
much younger I grew up certainly when
the notion of a United Ireland was would
have taken the form of a recolonization
you know where it was all about a kind
of a nationalist reversal
um of what had historically taken place
there's much more mature conversation
taking place in relation to that so it's
in that context I'd address this
question to both Sir John Bertie
um and it's it's the the Border poll
concept where it seems to me that much
more work needs to be done whether it's
in the assembly being up and running for
a substantial period of time
so that people have confidence in the
fact that the institutions and that were
provided for under the Good Friday
agreement actually work and should work
for a period of time and be seen to work
for a period of time before we would
approach that because otherwise it seems
to me
that it's just
trying to attempt a win a numerical wind
which isn't guaranteed of course because
there's so many topics it seems like a
black and white subject is not a black
and white it's obviously so many things
to be considered but just your
considered views both of you in relation
to the Border poll issue and and where
you think we should go on that of the
night thanks Jay
okay
um
maybe I I think case we should made a
issue about the reform and and I think
Nile made it as well and Regis
management so just take those together I
mean it it it is true that was the
executive powers
um and the fact that it wouldn't be
answerable in any way to uh to to storm
and to do new executive that that was
the concern and the length of the bodies
as well my own view is that we we should
be trying to cooperate in as many areas
as possible but one state the trust that
is that it's not all some hidden agenda
it makes absolute sense to be
cooperating they we've experts in
um of all kinds of areas across the
island and the more
um that we I'm involved in a charity
Epilepsy Foundation and some of the most
eminent people and these islands are in
here in the north some some of the South
and the whole island there's no Center
so you know the fact that people work
and cooperate on an online basis is is a
makes sense uh and I think we should
have far more bodies but uh and I think
that's happening almost uh unofficially
at least it was happening there were
more and more people cooperating and
working an awful lot today you know
business groups the farmers are
brilliant at this the farmers are
probably believe everyone behind because
they're really good at operating and
coordinating
um through all kinds of sectors so I
think that should happen
um the review mechanism of course is in
the in the agreement and
um Regis also right we we were we were
trying to resolve it something that we
hadn't been successful in during in 1998
we were trying to bring all parties in
and we were trying to bring the dup into
the uh into the into the process and the
review was was about that
um
whether my memory of it is that there
were there was an awful lot of objection
to some of the things that we did
afterwards and there wasn't as much at
the time we were doing it maybe it was
highlighted better afterwards but I do
accept that it made some of the issues
more difficult I I do accept that and
the review the reason
Kate I just want to be very clear in
this I I understand totally the alliance
um argument I understand absolutely the
argument they're making what I don't
want to see but and I feel there could
be a trap in this
that
um I know for a fact that if you try to
get around the cross community consent
issue and get parties to agree to set
that aside so that you can make the
changes it's not going to happen it just
won't happen so what I'm saying is
getting institutions up
and running and functioning and then you
can debate these issues if you do it the
other way around the institutions one
could open run and then believe me uh
that that's that that's what will happen
because I know what the what the others
are other parties are saying so I think
it's a it is a way you can argue about
the strength of your case
um afterwards
uh the the
um
John John the heart I think Mike said
that the point about the the work I
think there is a case
um
the institutions you know my position
I've said it a thousand times on the on
the border pole
um if you look what happened in Canada
some years ago if they're probably the
biggest referendum issues in in recent
decades Canada Scotland and brexit the
one thing you don't do is have a vote
until the work is done
if you have if you have a if you have a
vote and you put to the people and we're
having a vote on whatever it is and then
somebody says well explain to us now how
that's going to work in in practice
um how is the psni and the Garda Chicana
going to integrate how will that be
running
um who would be the commissioner and
who'll be the head and how are qcs and
sc's operate in the legal system of the
courts you know and how is the
integration of the Civil Service going
to be well I'll tell you what the result
of the vote will be and if you can't
answer the questions and I never
mentioned Finance
um you know when doubt you know but I I
was taught when I was playing under 10
football with home firm I was a left
full and when the ball went over my head
my coach always said well and they'll
pull it out
um and and that's exactly what people do
in politics too when in doubt to put it
out so if you can't answer the questions
so therefore so therefore
two things have to happen the stability
of the institutions has to be up and
running for a prolonged period whatever
that is I don't know what that plumper
is and the work has to be done now the
the work has only started and I think
there is an argument that there should
be far more work going on I think there
should be now there's I know the a
number of universities and academic
institutes and some private funders are
putting in considerable money so the
work is now been done and and it will it
will be done I mean I think that it will
come to a conclusion uh I've been asked
before when will I love that well I
don't know when it'll come to conclusion
but but I think it has to be said this
that
um and people forget this now
but it was an absolute integral part
of the Good Friday agreement
that there would be polls from time to
time
and the only reason we haven't had that
to date is because of the instability of
the institutions but it we would not
have had an agreement for that's a
reason but we wouldn't have had one
unless there was a path that the wood on
another day a big votes for people would
be able to see at moving to a uh we
started United are in 25 years ago
because that's what's in the agreement
um but so that so that issue is that we
have to remember that and we there are
some people now saying well you can
never have a vote you never sort of a
vote that that's that's not the
agreement so
um you have to leave that that one aside
so I think um
I think the the issue is John the
institutions been up and running stable
uh and and the work the necessary worked
so that it can be a case pot of white
paper or put to the people so people
understand what what the questions are
and until that's done you'll be wasting
taxpayers money having the vote because
the answer would be against it might
always be against but you'd certainly be
against if you can't answer the
questions
um so I think that's that that's that's
my uh my view I think that uh of course
the the one the one thing um
Regis dealt with this but
um the review mechanism in the agreement
is there
for looking at a broad range as issue as
John has had you know the the idea that
your agreement disagreement nothing
could be changed I mean that's a that's
a nonsense but
um
I suppose if you go back to the 2006 one
red you you could argue that maybe if
all the parties should along with the
two governments should have been across
the agreement maybe it would have been
been better but we were trying to fix a
particular aspect at the time we were
trying to bring in
um the Democratic Union's party into the
into the process because we thought that
was better for the long-term stability
of the of the agreement
let me I'll be very brief I'm not going
to to venture into this question of
cross-party consent and and so on
um I'm not
qualified to do so
um just one point on on the the north
south bodies
we were always a bit from a British
government point of view a bit bemused
at some times by this argument
um about how many there should be and
what the what the real problem was but
it was clearly very emotionally felt on
both sides
and of course the issue
was that it was seen by one side as this
is the slippery slope to unification I
mean obviously that's why people were
worried about them
um so that's why it had to be clear that
these were these were not ideologically
being bodies being set bodies being set
up for ideological reasons they were
there for practical reasons practical
cooperation which would benefit to both
sides and if that's the approach you
take then I think you can succeed if
they get to be seen as you know the
forerunners of unification or or a
slippery slope then opposition uh will
will continue
On the Border pole uh I mean my my
advice of what it's worth which I don't
think is much uh is that everybody
should be extremely careful about this
um you know you might not get more than
um one successful go at this
and I say that for two for two I mean
and you can either look at Scotland and
maybe it
um Quebec as Bertie was saying to to
learn lessons about this
um
if you rush into it
um because you think you've got them the
numerical majority if it's a 50 plus one
kind of vote he's always going to be
seen as something being done to one
group by another and it's
you may or may not win it but it's not
going to be a very successful process
and if you go into it in the spirit that
if we well
if we don't win this time we'll win next
time that's not the right way to go
about it somehow I feel um you know it's
it's that we only have to win once and
you know you have to win every time and
that that creates the wrong kind of
Dynamics about it if it's going to be
successful
for unification both in its result and
in its application implementation it's
got to be something which represents
something which you've evolved towards
and which comes to seem more natural
than it than it certainly seems at the
moment so I would cancel uh great care
and if you you know again if you rush
into it and you lose
and this is what the the SNP have
essentially done it's it's not so easy
to go back to it
um and I totally agree with what he says
if you're going to do it you have to do
the work first you have to be able to
answer the questions first which I think
the s p in notably did not do I'm
probably offending somebody around the
table here by saying that but anyway
that's kind of my my view for what it's
worth
thank you so much and I'm sorry we
couldn't bring more uh people in to ask
questions Margaret an email I promise
you are first on the list for the next
set of questions if you wish to ask a
question at that point
um we obviously have the debate later
and I'm sure that the
um contributions that we've received
today and what we've heard from Bertie
and Sir John will form part of our
discussions when we have our 90-minute
debate at the end of the day we are
significantly over time but I think we
all agree that it was wonderful to have
such eminent speakers and therefore we
should make the most of your time
um I'm going to close the session now
and tell everyone you have no more than
10 minutes and we will start the next
session at 22. absolutely firmly on time
because Karen Smith is going to be
facilitating it and she won't allow it
to start late so if you're late you'll
miss it thank you very much again to
bertia Hearn and John Holmes
and and please be back here for 22.
thank you